el costo de una visita al dentista es de
50 pesos
si el dentista tiene que tapar caries se
cobrará 100 pesos por cada caries si el
dentista encuentra n caries cuál será el
costo de la visita
escribe tu respuesta como una expresión
muy bien entonces queremos una expresión
de cuánto va a costar la visita y lo
primero que vamos a escribir es que la
visita va a costar 50 pesos no importa
que haga el dentista pero lo que también
dicen es que si el dentista encuentra
una caries y la tiene que tapar se va a
cobrar 100 pesos por cada una de las
caries aquí lo dice se cobrarán 100
pesos por cada caries
entonces si el dentista encuentra n
caries vamos a sumarle a estos 50 pesos
base de la consulta del dentista le
vamos a sumar 100
por en 100 n es decir 100 pesos por cada
una de las caries que encontremos y
vamos a ver si esto tiene sentido si tú
no tienes caries bueno n valdría 0 y
entonces 100 por 0 me daría 0 y
solamente pagarías el costo de la visita
al dentista si tienes una caries
entonces n balde a 1 y pagaría 50 que es
el costo de la visita más 100 por 1 si
tú tienes por ejemplo dos caries
entonces vas a pagar 50 más 100 por 2
esto tiene todo el sentido de estar bien
porque estás pagando según el número de
caries que tengas así que vamos a
comprobar la respuesta y vamos a hacer
uno más ahora vamos a hacer este de aquí
hay seis jugadores en el equipo de
hockey y pumas el equipo anotó un total
de 36 goles esta temporada uno de los
jugadores más yum anotó dos goles más
que el promedio por jugador cuántos
goles anotó más de uno escribe tu
respuesta
una expresión entonces para saber
cuántos goles anotó este jugador llamado
más yum
lo primero que hay que fijarnos es en
cuánto es el promedio de goles por
jugador porque aquí dicen más yo en
othón dos goles más que el promedio por
jugador así que para eso vamos a
fijarnos primero en cuántos goles se
metieron en total en esta temporada que
sabemos que es 36 goles entonces lo voy
a anotar aquí 36 y a esto lo voy a
dividir entre la cantidad de jugadores
que tienen este equipo de hockey pumas y
nos lo dicen a este jugadores en el
equipo de hockey pumas por lo tanto voy
a poner aquí abajo c&c y observa que
ahora esta expresión que tengo aquí
representa el promedio de goles que se
anotaron por jugador estamos dividiendo
la cantidad total de goles que se
metieron en la temporada dividido entre
el número de jugadores que tiene el
equipo pero bueno no queremos el
promedio por
queremos saber cuántos goles anotó
matthew así que esto le vamos a agregar
dos goles más porque es justo lo que nos
dicen entonces a esto le voy a sumar
de lujo observa que para saber cuántos
goles anotó este nación lo que hicimos
fue lo siguiente primero nos fijamos que
más de un anotó dos goles más que el
promedio por jugador entonces aquí dice
dos goles más muy bien hasta ahí vamos
bien y ahora vamos a fijarnos en esta
expresión que tenemos aquí esta
expresión que tenemos aquí es el
promedio de goles por jugador así que
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta muy
bien y vamos a hacer uno más bien ahora
vamos a hacer este que tengo aquí dice
hanna tiene 127 libros en su colección
su escuela organizó una donación de
libros hay 70 estudiantes en la escuela
y planean donar la misma cantidad de
libros cada uno y llegar a un total de
300 libros donados cuántos libros tendrá
gana en su colección después de hacer la
donación
escribe tu respuesta como una expresión
muy bien entonces lo primero que veo es
que hannah tiene 127
en su colección con eso vamos a empezar
y lo voy a anotar aquí gana tiene 127
libros en su colección vamos bien pero
después dice su escuela organizó una
donación de libros y hay z estudiantes
en la escuela y planean donar la misma
cantidad de libros cada uno hasta llegar
a un total de 300 libros donados cuántos
libros tendrán en su colección después
de hacer la donación bien hay que tener
cuidado yo en un principio me confundí y
hannah tenía 127 libros o si la escuela
tenía 127 libros pero no ya que lo
vuelve a leer ahora sí entiendo que
hannah tiene 127 libros y eso es lo que
sabemos y de estos 127 libros ella va a
donar una cierta cantidad de libros
cuántos libros va a donar bueno vamos a
ver qué dice hay siete estudiantes en la
escuela y planean donar la misma
cantidad cada uno de los estudiantes y
llegar a un total de 300 libros donados
entonces cuánto va a donar cada uno de
los alumnos
bueno quieren llegar a un total de 300
libros entonces voy a poner aquí 300
pero esto lo voy a dividir lo voy a
dividir entre la cantidad de estudiantes
que hay sabemos que hay 7 estudiantes en
la escuela es justo lo que me dicen aquí
entonces voy a dividir estos 300 libros
que es la cantidad total de libros a la
que llegaron entre zetas estudiantes
para así obtener el número de libros que
donó cada uno de los estudiantes así que
ganan empezó con 127 libros en su
colección pero de esos 127 libros ella
va a donar 300 entre zetas libros que es
lo que va a donar cada uno de los
estudiantes así que es hora de comprobar
respuesta
muy bien y vamos a hacer un último
ejercicio
vamos a hacer este ejercicio siguiente
dice elena perdió sus cánticos pero
luego las encontró y las puso en cuatro
bolsas con mecánicas en cada bolsa le
quedaron tres canicas que no quedaron en
ninguna bolsa cuántas canicas tiene
elena en total
escribe tu respuesta como una expresión
bueno sabemos que cuando elena encontró
sus canicas ella las puso en cuatro
bolsas con mecánicas cada bolsa eso qué
quiere decir bueno que en cada una de
las cuatro bolsas va a poner en
mecánicas por cada bolsa este es la
cantidad total de candidatas que tenemos
en las cuatro bolsas mecánicas por cada
una de las cuatro bolsas muy bien y
después dice que esta es la cantidad
total de canicas que tiene elena porque
le sobraron tres canicas que no quedaron
en ninguna bolsa entonces además de
estas canicas ella tiene otras tres
canicas más que no puso en ninguna
otra bolsa así que lo voy a escribir así
más otras tres canicas que ella no
colocó en ninguna de las bolsas y ahora
sí esta es la cantidad total de canicas
que tiene elena esta primera parte nos
dice la cantidad de canticas que tiene
elena en las cuatro bolsas y esto nos
dice que a ella le quedaron tres canicas
que no están en las bolsas
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta muy
bien hasta el siguiente vídeo